and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today today we're gonna talk
about how to start simplifying we're
gonna talk about how to become a
minimalist we starting all over well
some people are right we're gonna talk
about some practical tips and rules for
decluttering with today's guests and Jay
Gordon is here thank you for joining us
today I'm Jay pleasure I was first
introduced to you thanks to Jessica Lynn
Williams she is our talented social
media manager we call her social Jess
and she said hey you guys check out this
gals videos on YouTube so we'll put a
link to your YouTube channel in the show
notes that folks want to check it out
and you know today I just wanted to give
folks a refresher if they're looking at
getting started if they want to do some
spring cleaning in the fall and that was
a perfect time to do that at the end of
the year and and folks who are looking
to declutter or maybe you have someone
in your life and you're saying hey I've
simplified a little bit but they're the
people in your life are looking for some
ways to simplify and so maybe you can
send them this podcast episode and say
hey here are some practical tips for
simplifying your life we have a caller
driven show a listener driven show and
our first question today is from Jay in
Arlington Texas hey guys this is Jay
from Arlington Texas I'm moving to a new
house soon and my packrat wife has
caught the downsizing bug way more than
me I know this is a perfect opportunity
to minimize but for some reason I just
can't get excited about it and I'm the
one preaching minimalism any ideas now
Ryan this is the the best time to deal
with their stuff because as you both
know you're forced to deal with your
stuff when you're moving you're
confronting literally everything that
you own now I'm guessing Jay might find
some things in his attic or basement or
garage from the last time they moved and
still in boxes now I could tell you the
thing that Ryan did was a packing party
you want to talk real briefly about that
because this is their opportunity to
have their own sort of packing party oh
yeah yeah my
omma my grandmother she's going through
this right now - she's had to move
places so you're packing everything up
when you got all the boxes sitting in
your your new home just unpack things as
you need it that's what that's where I
started with minimalism Joshua's telling
me about how he spent months simplifying
and you know I didn't want to spend
months simplifying I needed like really
fast results so I'm like dude I'm just
gonna pack everything up and then I'm
gonna unpack it as I need it and that's
really gonna help me understand you know
the things that are adding adding value
to my life and it worked it was a great
experiment totally changed my whole
perspective we call it the packing party
because you know if you packing doesn't
sound fun but a packing party does sound
fun so Josh came over ordered some
pizzas and I drink some beers Josh
doesn't drink but but yeah it was a it
was a fun time we you know had you know
we were being goofy throughout the whole
whole whole thing but with Jay here how
ironic is it that like he's preaching
minimalism to his packrat wife she's
finally like oh yeah minimalism and now
he doesn't know what to do now here's
the thing and maybe MJ you can help out
with this he's having trouble getting
excited he says and so what would you
what would you tell Jay I think that's
understandable first of all you know
you've got the stress of all the move so
I understand but I think also getting
excited at this moment isn't necessarily
necessary so you know the extra stress
is more than what you need at a time of
move and if you don't feel like it maybe
just think what if right like just what
if I could let this this go what if I
can put some things aside what are the
things that I struggle with and sort of
allocate your things in that manner
before you actually let it go no once
all the stress is down then you can
revisit what you feel I think it's great
that his wife is excited about it yeah
she sees all this stuff and she's like
alright let's do it and he's like oh
well you know it's the excitement thing
I know that I struggle with when I need
to do work whether it's writing whether
it's paying taxes whether it's going to
the gym I mean when I'm putting in you
know there's this drug there's drug
jury I sometimes rely on excitement to
get me through it and that's a problem
because I can't always get excited about
all of these things so for me and what I
would recommend to Jay is find out what
is going to happen on the other side of
this simplifying so instead of looking
at it and thinking like oh there's all
this work to do I don't know where to
start
you know first off starting it just
starts small I mean start one little
room at a time yeah but I accept they're
there they're packed up at this point
well they're already packed up okay I
didn't get that from her so yeah so
start small let's start small and
unpacking room by room right or you
could do what I did with the packing
party unpack things as you need it
that's what I'm trying to talk to my
grandmother into doing but I'm like OMA
you you have to like if you really
because she's once to hold on to every
single thing and she can't fit
everything in a new home and it was like
kind of a hurry up
pack and move things so I know she needs
to get rid of a ton of stuff and I think
she's gonna take that approach but if I
find the benefits of what of what is
going to be on the other side so like I
wrote down some things like a.j your
wife is supporting you like this is a
great opportunity to help grow your
relationship like you can focus on that
you will have less stuff to clean you're
going to maybe make some extra cash if
you're going to you know sell some of
those items that you want to get rid of
think about the things that you donate
like that's going to add value to other
people's lives and there are many other
benefits that you can focus on but I
know for me when it comes to drudging
through the drudgery you know that is
that is something that has to be done in
order to get to that exciting point so
excitement doesn't necessarily come
first would you guys agree with that
absolutely yeah I think that that I
don't know about you but for me
decluttering is fairly boring and so it
I agree that it's often hard to get
excited about it
now Ryan and I have done a few things to
make it a bit more fun you can inject
some friendly competition and we have
something called the 30 day minimalism
game we'll put a link to that in the
show notes we've had tens of thousands
of people play this by adding just a
little friendly competition the packing
party is another way to make it more fun
because you can invite some friends over
and you can you know as you
unpacking your stuff you you can realize
like Oh most of the things that I packed
that I brought to this new home I
thought they were bringing me value but
it was all imaginary value I'm actually
not unpacking most of the things that
are just sitting there now in the living
room and I haven't I have a choice I
have an opportunity to do something with
that excess stuff yeah well I think when
it comes to new home what's exciting
about it is you know the buyers
experience right I mean we're talking
about minimalism but people like the
idea of a new home for creating space
not only do you have the opportunity to
do all the things you mentioned but
creating space is one of the I mean
that's the experience of walking into
that home that you want to buy this is
where my bed goes I love that this looks
like a model home so taking your items
and setting them up in that way and then
feeling that experience gets you excited
to say hey I don't need the rest of this
this is this is awesome the way that it
is yeah totally I would tell Jay to the
only other thing I would suggest is kind
of on the other side of the coin of all
this is really ask yourself Jay like
what are you afraid of like what is it
that is really stopping you from joining
him with your wife with this you know
minimizing your stuff I know for me like
the fear that I had because the packing
party that was easy the unpacking that
was exciting home doing something
different when I had to deal with all
the leftover stuff that was so stressful
the fear of letting go yeah it was a
fear letting go but it was also just the
work it was like I saw all these boxes
on my crap I got a leg I got a do donate
sell recycle you know I got have to
organize it and then when it comes time
to sell stuff like now I gotta do all
the work to sell all these things and
you know I had to get clear on what I
was what I was scared of so maybe
identifying those those obstacles Jay
and working with your wife to kind of
alleviate some of those fears and you
might not be able to alleviate every
single one of them but if you can
identify what they are I mean that at
least help you understand why you're
feeling the way you're feeling I do want
to talk more about fear in a moment Jay
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
everything that remains it's honestly my
favorite thing that we've ever written
it's the five-year journey that Ryan
went on from being the suit-and-tie
corporate guys in Dayton Ohio to
becoming minimalists and eventually the
minimalists and part of that had to do
with unpacking stuff but also unpacking
the fear that we had throughout the
entire journey so if you enjoy a podcast
I think you'll enjoy the audiobook
version of everything that remains or if
you want the book book or the eBook
version podcast Sean will send you one
of those as well Ryan what time is it
you know Tom it is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we are at the minimalists on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter MJ what are your
social media handles at Marin Jayden all
right link that in the show notes as
well now during the lightning round in
je what we try to do is we try to answer
each question with a short shareable
less than 140 character response but not
really we ramble on a bit and what
happens is podcast Ron heat wheezes out
something beautiful he puts it in the
show notes so people at home can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if they'd like and also Jessica
puts everything over at minimal Maxim's
calm as well so you can find all of our
pithy minimal Maxim's in one place all
right our first question is from Stephen
what is one unexpected result of your
transition to a minimalist lifestyle I
love how he didn't ask like what was the
unexpected positive result or negative
cuz it could be either here right it's
your good and Jay now that you've
embraced simple living do you have any
unexpected results good or bad or maybe
both yeah I just think it's the
experience of less it's truly more I
mean I used to think when somebody is a
successful in business why did they ever
stop and then I get to a place where I'm
ready to stop you know there's great
balance in my life I have time for
things I love I have patience for the
people I love and it feels amazing and I
think that's something that can't be
described in words you just have to
experience it you're experiencing enough
in a way whereas before it was it was
never enough and I think we never
stopped where we very rarely stopped to
ask what is enough and especially in
business that the the sort of
the sort of mantra of most businesses
infinite growth we have to we have to be
up year-over-year quarter-over-quarter
we go over week and and grow grow grow
and forsake everything for the sake of
of growth as opposed to saying okay what
what does enough actually look like and
then when that applies to all the other
areas of our life our homes our
relationships our money your whatever it
might be identifying what is enough for
you and by the way that enough will
probably change over time when I first
embraced minimalism I was 28 years old
and I'm 38 now with a six year old
daughter so my life looks different and
so what's enough for me and my family is
a bit different from what was enough for
my 28 year old self my my pity answer
here is and I'd like to unpack this as
well but it's minimalism is not unlike a
horizon once you arrive a new horizon
appears and I think that's the thing we
often think like I'm just gonna do my
packing party I'm just gonna do the
30-day minimalism game I'm just gonna
implement the the 90 90 rule I
legitimately thought the packing party
was gonna solve all my problems and all
I did was help me see all my other
problems I guess if I were to answer his
his question directly the the most sort
of unexpected result was I still have
problems however they're better problems
to have and I think maybe that's the key
to growth and contentment we're never
gonna eliminate our problems if you
eliminate all your problems your life's
gonna be really boring because you're
not gonna have any challenges in life
and so the idea is to have problems
still but to have better problems so
when you get to that horizon there's
still gonna be the next horizon you're
gonna want to get to go to and so
simplify in my life it wasn't like well
here's the minimalist rule book here are
the 150 items you should own in order to
be happy that would be easy but that
wouldn't be simple because it wouldn't
be deliberate and so for me my life is a
whole lot more deliberate right now and
and I continue to question the things I
guess the other thing that was
unexpected is it does get easier to
question the things in your life the
more you ask the questions like does
that value to my life you-you-you get
clear on what is valuable but you still
get infected by marketing messages I was
reading the New Yorker magazine the
other day and I saw a Rolex ad on the
back now I have written an essay about
how a Rolex won't buy you more time yet
I see the Rolex I'm like wow that's nice
I don't wear a watch so what am i doing
why am I even thinking of this just
shows you how good they are man do you
ever get infected by these what were the
things that you look at you're like I
should get that watch yeah yeah travel
cars Instagram some reason like that I
see it I'm like oh yeah I've made that
mistake too many times already where I
see a shirt on someone I'm like oh
that's a great shirt and then I put it
on like look good on that person does
not look good on me article once that I
read not sure how true it is but I read
and I took it to heart it said when you
window shop but you don't buy it
actually increases your happiness it's
when you do buy that you start dealing
with decision fatigue buyer's remorse
cost sunk costs by whatever bias and so
I said okay I'm gonna try this
I took an Amazon wishlist I piled it all
in there I still do this to this day I
go shopping on Amazon pile it all in
there and I'm like okay I'm just gonna
wait six months later delete delete
delete delete new stuff it's just so
awesome you just overpass all of those
negatives you know yeah no that's
brilliant
umm it's funny cuz lately so I always
talk about getting a Tesla cos like
being in LA they're everywhere and
they're I really like those cars you
know zero emissions I could go on and on
um I had a dream not too long ago that I
like just did it I went out and got a
Tesla you know took money out of my
house fund to go you know spent on this
Tesla and I was like I wasn't miserable
but I wasn't happy I was like in my
dream I was driving it and it's like
driving itself I was like this is cool
but like
I just gave up my house for this and
like it was but but to your point it's
like the the I like talking about
getting a Tesla I think more than if I
actually was to get a Tesla yeah like to
your point it's it's like you you have
these things to shoot for and that you
know will keep your your energy up or
keep your attitude up and then like as
soon as you get it and it doesn't give
you the result that you anticipated yeah
like I could totally see where that
would it would make you miserable
whereas not getting it you still have
this like anticipation which there's
something about you know us humans that
love that that anticipation that build
up we call the hedonic treadmill once
you get the thing and then you become
accustomed to the thing I mean we all
see it now with the the iPhone 11 is out
and and it's like well my current iPhone
works just fine until they inject the
planned obsolescence into it reinforce
the stuff great but the the whatever
phone it's like I see that I'm like oh
maybe I should have that because there's
three cameras on it or whatever it is
and I noticed that I look at that once I
get the thing and you feel the burst of
joy if you bought the Tesla you'd feel
the the burst of joy and you probably
enjoy driving it but it still get you
from here to there the same way your or
2004 Toyota Corolla does which i only
use maybe once a week right and so I you
asked a beautiful question he said about
the about giving I had to give up my
house for this maybe that's a question
the deposit with if I'm gonna bring this
new thing into my life what do I have to
give up for it because you have to give
up money which is an important resource
but what are the other resources you're
giving up your time your attention your
freedom I mean if you're buying a Tesla
how many years do you have to work to
pay to pay for a Tesla you know when we
think about these things and it may make
sense to say yes this makes sense to me
I'm going to I'm going to bring it into
my life deliberately but understanding
what you're parting with will help you
make a better decision there's something
about like working a job that you hate
and then rewarding yourself by taking on
more debt because you can afford so many
debt payments that forces you to
continue to work a job that you hate
yeah I'm working a job to pay for the
car to get me to the job to pay
the car and it becomes as weird sort of
circular problem yeah you know it's this
isn't my pet the answer had nothing new
thought but something you said about the
problems that we have on our lives like
we humans are problem solvers like we do
need these challenges and one of the
benefits I think minimalism does is you
get to choose more problems now
sometimes and often we have problems
that we can't control but there are a
lot of problems we have that we bring on
ourselves and I living that deliberate
life helps us choose our problems more
deliberately which is which is a good
thing my pity answers is the benefits of
minimal the benefits of minimalism are
different and plentiful for everyone I
mean it is there are so many unexpected
benefits you know this stuff I was
talking to Jay about you know just less
time cleaning alone like I just had no
idea I was like oh like you have the
less stuff I have I don't have to spend
as much time each week cleaning my
things let's talk about some of those
benefits real quick for me I mean the
first one was was finance what was
finances I I realized that I've made
really good money but spent way too much
money and so I had I made good money but
I was still in debt and so I didn't
really have financial freedom but then I
started noticing a cascade of other
benefits the easier to clean your house
is a beautiful one but there were so
many others my relationship started to
improve the clothes that I wore I
actually enjoyed more because I got rid
of the excess or I got rid of the desire
to impress other people with the clothes
I wore and I wear clothes that are
comfortable for me and that I feel good
and Jay what are some of the benefits
you experience from simplifying your
life I think the biggest benefit I got
was lowering my baseline of expectancy
because let me tell you when I had a
tempur-pedic mattress I couldn't sleep
anywhere except at home or else I'd get
a backache now that I sleep on the floor
which was an accident by the way but we
sleep on the floor
I can sleep anywhere you know honestly
he's probably more minimal practical
than I am he's very you know stoic by
Nature Dayton Ohio
yeah on board with anything right
ohayo people are just you know super fun
like that but that was that was the
biggest thing it's it seems really weird
but we lose our resilience to stress
when we pander to our comforts all the
time and I never thought you know so the
words out of my mouth that's other
things that are similar to that where
where you have lowered your threshold
for for comfort but you've improved your
life as a result yeah Ryan and I will
often say the place from which you grow
is actually the discomfort zone when you
make yourself a little uncomfortable
what are well there are other areas
where you've made yourself uncomfortable
Jim every single day right we can all
relate to that but I do things like I
have a I have a weighted blanket that
someone gifted me and it's so soft and
you know it's something that I want to
wear or use every single night my
daughter has one oh do you yeah it's so
awesome but if I sleep with that just
like sleeping on the Tempurpedic bed
then I can't sleep with a sheet or
anything else so I only use it when I'm
sick or when I need extra comfort or I'm
having a hard time sleeping and it makes
that blanket extra amazing instead of an
everyday occurrence yeah yeah so I try
it with everything now you know cold
showers and so every time I'm like just
a little warmer no colder no cold air I
say friendly you know who's like play
this game with myself but every time you
get that jacket on or you put that
shower up just a little warm it's just
amazing like it's the icing on the cake
and they're just simple things yeah I
think comforts are killing us I mean
they really are and if we live if we
infinitely nerf our world and we're all
wrapped in bubble wrap all the time it
may seem comfortable but it's a type of
prison it's a type of tyranny in a way
because we then expect everything to be
comfortable and as soon as some some
twinge of discomfort and there's our
life it we we panic because we don't
know how to to deal with it are your are
our bodies do this
you know when we do hot and cold therapy
like if you do saunas and cold plunges
and and that type of thing you you have
a hermetic response to that and the same
with some vegetables that we if you eat
it's almost like you eat a certain toxin
even and sanaa culated yourself what
it's really doing is it's producing a
stress response within your body now too
much of that is obviously a bad thing
but just enough of it
just enough discomfort makes you a
stronger person it makes you able to
deal with with well with just about
anything a lot better than if your life
is infinitely comfortable well then all
of a sudden if you're hiking let's say
in Greece because you're saved up and
you don't want to travel
you're not seeing I mean I don't notice
that I have a blister on my foot or that
I'm a little bit cold and I'm busy
enjoying because those discomforts don't
hold me back or as you know say my
travel partner who it's not used to this
kind of approach is complaining about
how hot it is and how their feet hurt
and you know so those are some of the
benefits to not that we're here to you
know decrease our our own yeah we don't
want to deprive ourselves and it's I
mean it's like we're I think what we're
talking about is just this balance
between being you know deprivation and
being completely comfortable and there
is there is a healthy balance I think
one of the best pieces of advice I got
when I was in the corporate world is I
was like complaining about how stressful
my job was and the guy was complaining
too he was like did you know there are
some stresses like there's a healthy
amount of stress in life that you do
want to have now I would argue that he
just wasn't hearing when I was talking
about and with my old job but what he
said really resonated with me and I'm
like yeah you know what coz because what
happens
well what happened to me I got to a
point where it was so stressful that I
wanted to alleviate all the stress and
if I could flip a switch and just be a
hundred percent comfortable that's what
I would have done and I mean I guess
it's kind of what we do go from one
extreme to the other sometimes but but
yeah recognizing that there is a healthy
amount of stress and finding a way to
put that into
our lives like it's yeah it's super
important I read a quote recently that
said success is one-half stress one-half
rest and and that's what you talked
about with the balance right like you
you do need those moments of stress that
the discomfort really but then you also
do need the moments of of rest or or
comfort if you have all stress all the
time you're gonna be wildly stressed out
if you're comfortable all the time
you're not gonna grow you're not gonna
feel successful you're gonna you're
gonna feel like you're not doing
anything with your life and so you
definitely both yeah absolutely
Carmen writes in I want to simplify so
badly I visualize it so much I can
almost touch it but then I get paralyzed
really I cannot act on anything what's
my problem
decision fatigue fear something else how
do I break this cycle well so we wanted
to talk about fear everyone to touch on
fear I think many of our fears are are
wildly irrational right I think about
with the fear of letting go Ryan was
talking about when we start to
articulate some of these fears out loud
we realize how silly our fears are I
know for me when when I actually early
on when we started the minimalists calm
I did an experiment where I got rid of
my favorite shirt and my favorite pair
of pants and my favorite shoes because
some reporter asked me like what what
are three things you can't live without
what are your favourite things and I'm
like well I can live without pretty much
anything but here are my favourite
things and I sent a question I will wait
a minute why are these my favourite
things and why would I be afraid to let
go of them and and the excuse up put in
my head or like well people like me more
if I wear this t-shirt but when I say
that out loud it sounds like oh of
course that's not true or if it is true
I'm hanging out with the wrong people
and so my short answer has to do with
with fear here and and that is well I
have to for you the first one is you
will experience exponential growth if
you fill your to do let to-do list with
your trepidations
and I think that's the thing if you are
afraid of something it probably needs to
be tackled head-on if you want to be
able to deal with it if sleeping on the
floor you're afraid of that
put it on your to-do list because then
you can at least tackle it and you may
decide well that's not for me I'm gonna
go back to having a bed but I'm no
longer afraid of doing it once I've done
it my other short answer here is letting
go begins with loosening your grip so if
I'm talking to to Carmen here right now
she has a tight hold on everything right
yeah I want to simplify so badly and so
even the wanting to simplify she has a
tight hold on yeah I visualize it so
much I can almost touch it mmm
tight hold on that even and so having a
tight hold on everything you don't let
go right away you just have to loosen
your grip on those things because if
everything is precious than nothing is
precious and and you have some things in
your life you know you can let go of and
we have some tips and tricks you can
find our website I'd love to put a link
to the thirty thirty rule the ninety 90
rule and the twenty twenty rule in the
show notes those are three things that I
think will will help you out but I'll
just go over the the twenty twenty rule
real quick we also call it the just in
case rule and so MJ the what Ryan and I
found early on is we were holding on to
a lot of things just in case I just hold
on this one just in case I need it
someday and some hypothetical future and
I was holding on to literally thousands
of items just in case I might need it
someday
and what I realized is that I could get
rid of these things because I'm not
actually using any of the just in case
items and we can't the rule we came up
with the reason we call it 2020 is
anything that you get rid of just in
case you can replace for less than
twenty dollars in less than 20 minutes
from wherever you are now that sounds
like a really expensive rule if you had
to use it every single day I don't want
to spend 20 bucks a day
but Ryan and I have been doing this for
a decade now and between the two of us
we've had to use it five times I can
count literally on one hand how many
times I've had to replace it just in
case items so it's cost us $100 to use
this rule and over the course of a
decade I've been able to let go of
thousands of items as a result so way
less than a storage unit
costs oh my gosh can you imagine a
storage unit full of just-in-case items
that's my nightmare yeah are there
things that you've that you held on to
just in case or maybe do you have any
rules that have helped you or would help
Carmen simplify and like oh I did yeah
it was my husband who was like I wonder
how much you've paid for this over the
length of time and if it was worth the
cost of all the items and it wasn't and
that was my first probably real
awareness of the minimalism philosophy
but to answer your question I ran into
this idea from the essentialism book the
essential is yeah and what he was saying
was the thing that stuck with me is if
if I don't have this item right now
would I be willing to pay for it again
or what would it would it would it cost
me to buy it again right now right that
changed my life that one it's good you
got some pity for us yeah the pithy
answer is this a plan is useless without
action so Carmen you got to start
somewhere I agree with Josh like I think
I would start with the rules and some of
these rules like you might look at like
I know an artist they always push back
on the 9090 rule they're like well there
are some things I know I'm going to use
probably not going to use them in the
next 90 days but I know that there is a
project okay great if you don't have a
rule though then you're gonna hang on to
everything so maybe it's the 365 365
rule so Carmen you know look at the
rules that Josh and I have for ourselves
and see if those fit and if they don't
then make some adjustments that fit for
your life that'll help you at least get
a baseline on where to start but again
you can come up with all the rules and
all the plans and all the thoughts if
you don't take that first step then that
plan is useless so Carmen starts small
you know you said something Josh about
her holding on to holding on to that
grip of I just want to minimize now I
know exactly what I you know what I want
to do that grip is this could be
petrifying because she's looking at
everything all at once she's seeing the
end result of what she wants and all of
this work that takes to get there and
that can
very paralyzing yep so pick a closer
horizon yeah exactly so instead of
looking at oh I want this perfect house
with perfectly organized look at your
bedroom closet and start with that me
like okay how can I make this bedroom
closet perfectly organized just take
little steps and it was every little
step you take it will add up to be
something huge on the maximal today
we're going to talk about five ways to
overcome decision fatigue and boost
willpower number three on that list I
just want to read it real quick this is
from our friend James clear because I
think this really applies to Carmen
number three is stop making decisions
start making commitments and he says I
think advice like you just need to
decide to do it gets dished around way
too much yes of course you need to
decide to do things that are important
to you but more than that you need to
schedule them into your life and so
that's the thing you were talking about
Ryan
having having the plan yeah that's
important but you're not willing to
actually do something with that plan
then it's a useless plan right we all
have things that we say are important to
us I really want to scale my business I
really want to lose 40 pounds I really
want to get started on XYZ or in
Carmen's case I want to simplify so
badly unfortunately most of us hope that
we'll have the willpower and motivation
to make the right decisions each day
rather than hoping that I'll make the
right choice each day I found much more
success by scheduling the things that
are important to me and he goes on to
explain his own schedule we'll talk
about that more on on the Maxwell but
Carmen the the thing you can do right
now is you can schedule simplifying into
your life yeah what if you were to
schedule Monday Wednesday Friday an hour
a day for each of those days and just
during that time it's the only time I'm
gonna simplify but I'm gonna get these
things out of my house I'm gonna use
some of the rules we'll put in the show
notes whether it's the 1 in 10 out rule
whether it is the the just for win rule
or the 30 day minimalism game whatever
you want to do but you're gonna spend
some time it's gonna be on your calendar
and you're gonna take that time every
week to simplify your life it's called
chunking it's just taking these little
chunk
at a time not worrying about the
ultimate end result but having it on
your calendar right now all right before
we dive into our added value segment and
our listener tips and tricks today it
looks like we got a bunch more surprise
questions this week including what does
a minimalist shopping list look like
Ryan get your shopping list out when
starting now should you focus on
external items or internal issues how do
I let go of all the books magazines and
catalogs I hold on to we're gonna talk
about that because that was something I
struggled with I had a huge horde of
catalogs and really magazines but also
man I had like two thousand books we're
gonna talk about that what if one person
in the relationship wants to minimize
and the other person doesn't what are
the differences between minimalism and
the con Mari method also we're gonna
talk about MJ's decluttering checklist
she has a whole checklist to help you
declutter and much much more with MJ
Gordon and if you want to hear all that
you can listen to this week's maximo
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you currently listen to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I record an entirely different
much much much longer maximal episode I
think we answer like three or four times
the questions on the maximal episode
it's over on the minimalists private
podcast that private podcast gives us
the private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public Plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll receive a personal link
so that our maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you can find
all the details and all the good stuff
including an additional private podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists com slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week it's time
Josh for your favorite part in my
favorite part voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi my name is Becca I'm from Columbus
Ohio I'm calling with a tip for Tracy
who commented in the episode about
organization that her pantry was getting
out of hand again and this is the
problem I have had also I've gotten it
down to a system I discovered that part
of the reason my pantry was getting out
of hand is because I like adventures in
food so now I have my pantry organized
by type for me that you know that means
I have a shelf for beans for greens or
for grains and then a shelf for nut you
know everything by type but then I have
a special area in my pantry for
adventures like I like to bake so I have
a lot of flowers and there's a whole
section just for different and
interesting gluten-free flours like
mesquite flour and coconut flour and
then when that section gets full I know
I'm on put myself on a little bit of a
ban so one time my chocolate shelf got
really full so I was on the chocolate
buying ban until I used up my chocolate
I've also had a TV and band just to help
me really focus on enjoying those items
that I have acquired and purchased so I
hope that is helpful tip for you just
help keep yourself in check with new and
interesting foods Thanks hello this is
Lynn from South Africa I've got it for
those people that are looking through
perhaps a nostalgic paperwork I'm
looking through my daughter's baby boxes
now I'm seem to keep more to to us and a
good idea would actually just have to be
listen to the podcasts while you sorting
through and it can be quite a emotional
time and you get revved up maybe in your
old thoughts and memories and and then
just to kind of bring clarification
again this class has to be listening to
the podcast and saying and remind
yourself why are you doing this so
that's my suggestion all right so thanks
again to M Jay Gordon for joining us
today you can check her out at MJ -
Gordon comm will also put a link to her
YouTube channel in the show notes real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists head on over to the
minimalists comm slash wallpapers I was
just on the phone with Dave yesterday
Ryan Davis our talented designer he's
done all of our book covers and actually
designed our website well I designed our
website he redesigned it and the the
only thing I've ever designed is our
logo mm-hmm in my life it's the
one accomplishment and so I've I've set
aside the masterpiece and I've walked on
you're talking about the minimalists
yeah yeah yeah and but dave is designed
pretty much everything else that we've
we've done including any posters like
tour posters or book covers movie cover
etc he's designed at all well we're
working on a whole series of wallpapers
to help you declutter your phone we
already have a few of them out there
right now there's three or four of them
we have to love people use things
wallpaper we've got the lesses now
wallpaper you have Ryan's of my favorite
the minus sign the subtract sign the
minimalism sign we call it and so I
think that's the one that Ryan and I
both use is the subtract sign but then
we also have the five questions to ask
before buying so I have this one on my
phone currently I'm a few if you've
downloaded it yet Ryan but any time I
pull out my phone it's right here these
five questions I should ask myself more
mine so if I'm standing at at the
checkout line at Target or something and
I'm late
okay can I afford to part with this
money can I pay the actual cost will it
add value to my life one of the
alternatives can I get by without it for
a while hey I'm I need that I'm forced
to ask myself these questions and you
can download these for free we want to
help you declutter your smartphone head
on over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers we're also working on some
other ones scrolling is the new smoking
measure DM they're relatively soon I
think that's perfect for the the
smartphone we should do like a no
scrolling Sun probably like a hand I
don't know yeah anyways anything with a
ghost poster symbol over it later so
actually the name I'm blanking on the
name of it anyway
the minimalists comm slash wallpapers
you can get all the free wallpapers well
we're also working on one you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you so I think
we're gonna have seven or eight of them
total up there plus it's not just for
your phone it's for your desktop as well
so you can declutter your desktop with
any of our beautiful wallpapers and any
of these you can also print out as well
so when you download it you have the
option to also download the
eight-and-a-half by eleven so I find the
five question
we've had a lot of people already print
that out and put it like by their desk
as they're in to hop onto Amazon and and
waste their money
there's five questions for that so the
minimalists comm slash wallpapers you
can find all the free wallpapers there
and it will continue to grow so you can
continue to check back if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo the podcast at
the minimalists comm you can comment on
this episode youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want our show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
just head on over to the minimalists
comm and your email address at the top
there will never send you any spam never
send you any junk but you'll also
receive our simple Sunday emails with
anytime we write something new any new
essays to go up on the website you'll
get those right there in your inbox for
our added value this week let's listen
to a new song from Caitlyn Tarver right
I just stumbled across this gallon the
music her music is amazing but this song
in particular it's called cynical it's a
brand new song and it's just a single it
is a single it must be good if you are
recommending I don't like singles oh
yeah me either
it made me dive into her back catalogue
because I heard the song and I was blown
away because it perfectly captured the
sort of discomfort the dis-ease
we have with scrolling through all the
pictures on Instagram and feeling
inadequate and then becoming cynical as
a result so let's finish this episode
with Caitlyn Harper's song cynical and
if you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus